in this episode of the google secret
manager video series
we'll talk about how secret manager can
aid in threat detection
and forensic analysis where can you find
a list of all requests to google secret
manager
stay tuned to find out
[Music]
while we always want to do as much as we
can to prevent a data breach
a good security threat model also
accounts for the unexpected
and helps us respond in the event of a
compromise
all too often organizations invest
all their resources in prevention
and then they leave no bandwidth for
detection
or recovery cloud audit logging
is a fully managed logging service that
once enabled
provides a forensic history of
interactions with google secret manager
it also works with other google cloud
products but this episode focuses
specifically on secret manager
to tell us more about cloud audit
logging and how it can help with
forensics
i think we need to bring in an expert
hey tommy thanks for joining us today
thanks seth thank you for having me
so tommy is a software engineer who
works on google secret manager
tommy earlier i was telling our viewers
about
cloud audit logging and how it keeps a
detailed list of
all interactions with google secret
manager that's right seth
but there's an important first step oh
what's that
you have to turn them on admin write
audit logs
which include any changes to secrets are
enabled by default
but admin read logs which include
viewing secret metadata
and data read logs which log secret
access
are disabled by default because of the
amount of data
they generate okay but what if i have my
secret stored across
multiple projects do i have to enable it
on each project or
how does that work you can enable cloud
audit logs on a per
product basis and you can choose to
enable logs for admin read
admin write data read data right
or any combination okay but
to rephrase my last question where do i
turn them on
at the project level or how do i manage
this at scale
ah great question cloud audit logs
are configured through iem and can be
enabled on a single project
for all projects in a folder or for all
projects in an
entire organization this means a
security team
can configure an organization-wide
policy that automatically applies to all
current and future projects okay and
and then what do i do after i turn them
on that's it
oh this is
kind of awkward then why
we just we had a lot more back and forth
with our
other experts i guess cloud audit
logging really is this easy
yep
i'm gonna go now
cool uh thanks tommy thanks seth
okay let's look at how we enable and
consume
cloud audit logs for google secret
manager
now that we've enabled cloud audit
logging all requests
to access and manage secrets in this
project will generate
a log entry i'll go ahead and access a
secret
so it generates such an audit log entry
these audit logs are written to cloud
logging
google cloud's centralized logging
solution
which you can easily access from the
sidebar
from here you can filter by log type
including audit logs
for particular services for example
suppose you suspected that a service
account credential
had been compromised here in the log
viewer
you can filter for all requests to
access secrets
using that service account you can then
correlate that data against
time stamps source ip addresses and more
google secret manager's integration with
cloud audit logging
brings a wealth of forensic information
to your fingertips
with a click of a button that's all for
this episode
and this concludes our secret manager
series
to learn more about secret manager visit
us on the web
at cloud.google.com forward slash secret
dash manager
and be sure to like subscribe and click
the bell
to get notifications about new and
upcoming video series
on security ai ml
databases storage and so much more
[Music]